[Music]
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a caller
accurately identifying that right
wingers are better than left wingers at
firing up their bases
hello david uh great show listen all the
time this is brent and my question is
it seems like every weekend the
republicans and the mega
radicals are holding a rally either a
trump rally or a cpac rally or a turning
point rally
into rally after rally after rally
however you don't see any of this on the
left
is that a bigger problem
or
am i the only one that thinks that the
problem that
the right has all these ridiculous
rallies that seems to rile up the base
and the left has nothing to counter that
i have been saying this for years the
pyrotechnics
the wrestling style introductions the
explosive music everything
it's all pathetically cringe-worthy and
we all recognize it as such
and also
it is more of the evidence it's more
it's it's these are greater and greater
examples
of how the right creates community
and funds this stuff
to activate and engage and inspire and
fire people up in a way that the left
does not now i'm not suggesting that we
try to fire people up in the exact same
way i mean a lot of this stuff
it
it appeals to the right more than it
appeals to the left so i'm not saying we
do the same thing but the left would
greatly benefit from a decision
that we have to pour more money into
activating engaging and inspiring people
and if we don't
we're going to lose the ground game and
we continue to lose it in many ways so
yeah the caller is a hundred percent
correct
on today's bonus show pac-man's a loser
i know alex jones hates the bonus show
we are going to talk about steve
bannon's two guilty counts and his
likely sentence we are going to talk
about new sex education books rejected
by a florida school board and we will
talk about support from two-thirds of
americans for term limits in the supreme
court all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com